hi you've come to the right place here  you can learn how to learn languages who  proved it upon come on up on they long  though you finished a guy tropical drink  osaka kyoto kobe benkyo suru koto LA  take him us take a diva  nakisha da Lucas gy a kiss avoid a  aprender como aprender idiomas a key vas  a pas de aprender como aprender linguist  qui se pone para ray kumo in / re la  lingua H I eat put touch sign that come  sandwich in veg limbus stress strain  here currency learnin the much broken  down hair candle holiday Adler day at  last stroke I need on a Heuer Hawk  hopped out Tim iam home ye-es we merged  here with nudge [ __ ] switch it Y Z key  neighbor of chess ginger the machete  mmm does V edit does yet a yak say would  cheat yuzuki mama messing my most recent  language yo ESO a at okay way go go  component goes on a pero su e Sumida so  subscribe to my channel